[Music]
in him
or not
because he is starting to learn to drive the
first thing he likes is to run but I want to
control a calculated man who completely
calls me the gaza
[Music]
in other countries they say the rules are
illegal in Cuba and with the world he thinks
which is a bit like a lamborghini a ctr
here a car has been running since 1930
I was one of the most recognized
in illegal racing achieve your son
comes following in his footsteps and he has
his blood inside
[Music]
in the year of sense  they stop the
mud races in Cuba thanks to the bone
what the clubs have more or less been
doing competitive activities all
seeing permission from the government to the police
[Music]
they talk to you about the rule in Cuba and they don't
mention peer and they don't know anything that  it's
races already gave more than 16 years to
humiliate him unfortunately from 2006
a strong blow that gave me life
I was diagnosed with cancer
I didn't feel bad I said they won't take me to
the races go sailing and I saw the race
and I felt good yes to med  going to
get rid of the pain and ciro is a
state of love
I am a medical student but I do not
like cars I have two passions it
is about water dma and six doctors and
also network games race and follow the
tradition that has been laid down
here we have
my car that was turning 15 I was
doing modification
21 to the things that I say yes to
learn to run you have to learn to
fix the car
[Music]
I always imagined that I was going to do
mechanical engineering and focus on medicine
because I wanted to be  doctor in the future
of priests
the two things are related because
medicine has to fix life and
things like it does with engines and parts
and then each doctor will have time
[Music]
in one day I was taking down the pizzas and
live an adventurer and the track
flew away a client fell on her face yes
because I didn't have time to yell at the
client
[Music]
I'm marta 1 the most day and they
marked she loves him today
[Music]
2 a  guayana
at the beginning we took it down the stairs,
we got very tired with the pizza walking
and people
gave us ideas and the idea came up of taking
a sixth to lower the pencil through the balcony
[Music]
the most way musician by Ángel Pérez  pérez
the first pete reed life kit would seem to
be called my way because you ask for
the track your way and we from
the m system of scalpel under high pressure
martín and bones grup scout augusto max
potter was classified in the first visit in
the mass and  in the sauce and each track has
its recipe each viscera of its sauce in its own
way they do not tell their secret
[Music]
we have tried to maintain the
same type of dough here it is also manual
[Music]
the quality of the rush is
indisputably good  people
from the beach come here from the beach municipality nobody goes to
buy maybe the pizza helps the Cuban
because it helps people to survive and to
escape
[Music]
smart
business if it's the norm
the d can do anything to you  Brands can
make any decision or that it was
sacred we have the power to decide
about what makes it easy what is
best for the business I always try to
do things laughing and laughing
ourselves because because the laughter of
happy day and the smile has
tremendous students
well
just like introducing the week when the
green light where you sit on the web
was the exception of the 69 reduced and
fiberglass I decided today leader of weights of
weights
although when writing it pérez nievas is
good new life and life with the beaver
the restaurant  disney and science one by
one with the project habana light
univision third they sell outside that sells
filtration forest the nasn website they
maintained in cuba such a sensation smells
receive guarantees came before from
architects but night in texts they had
sandvik anti-football expansoft maintain in
their staff in  the aesthetics
[Music]
[Applause]
today they had consider the one who stepped
on mission organization kick off the art
walker in de  build the garden then i
sit on the fifth floor ford and more
trailers than virgins have
virtuality are behind series
beijing 20 companies is enjoying
fiction author of fiction edition
of the merz roster
the most critical is also of the style of
verifying in the egg
we can  complicate the process and the
literal fact that there are at least seven countries
negotiating yesterday from robert kurz in the
great that they do not want jr
this does not happen people would know although that
suisse and amounts of diesel
bolt outlet feel like western auto he says
but also back to live
unions the minsa restoration with hold my
life
javier well from phoenix tranquility
[Music]
I am not only electric but also a
kind of general cultural question
in the middle of the 19th century there is a workshop
that decides to choose a not scared that it
was to read literary works  with
the aim of raising their cultural level,
then it became generalized because
somehow all the workshops
were interested  s in this type of
performance
[Music]
kirchner works lucio walk in the morning campaign on the
web
increased his character in star whittington
oriental with eggs and beats from the front they don't
jump and blues in superior marketing information
and report
[Music
] I usually try to  wright issues that
influence their daily work in how to
deal with various problems also
on specific dates where there are
historical commemorations where there are
birthdays I
always bring you something related to
the dates as well as people because
it broadens their level of knowledge and
opens arms with bulgaria
generally, when an hour was over,
a kind of survey in the last
survey they wanted something of the
adventure genre I proposed several works and they
chose the last one they modify it is the one
that he is currently reading let's go
to the opening of
latitude last I like my  work, I think it
fulfills a very important objective not
only from the cultural point of view
but  also from the point of
view of being able to deal with problems
that arise daily and that
through reading sometimes we give solutions to
some issues that they do not face,
there is a saying in Cuba that says that they
have marked so that they take out the  woman who
alleges that she turns me on because
she has stayed
[Music]
in the last six markets he
costs
in the agreement and they are chops they
felt old clothes canes rice and
beans you say the quality they see and neox
they write them tennis restaurant food
china go there girlfriend
and already
[Music]
the quality of the air
here at the hacienda suited me [ __ ]
here my name and antonio wong just like
a quality is good nightingale and sex
and bone a samaná active in nike insists
human
celebrate at  that they were going because
maybe with this legislation they will
hold conviction in cairo where
there is form
[Music]